now tonight as you can imagine democrats
the mob and the media they're not
exactly taking today's ruling very well
on twitter twitter senator sheldon
whitehouse promoted a conspiracy theory
that the supreme court was being
influenced by quote dark money meanwhile
california governor gavin newsom he's
dying for attention proclaiming it was a
dark day in america one democratic
strategist tweeting quote well sometimes
mass shooters wear robes and don't have
a gun and then there's the out of work
espn analyst keith olbermann poor keith
he called for the supreme court to be
dissolved and then went on to shout
profanities at the justices and even
referred to amy coney barrett as a
paralegal of course joe biden is also
upset about the ruling the guy that left
uh 80 billion dollars in the most
sophisticated weaponry of war in the
hands of the taliban doesn't trust his
fellow law-abiding americans to have a
firearm the guy that also told his wife
if you if i'm not here and there's any
trouble take the shotgun and shoot it
twice take a look
it's uh i think it's a bad decision i
think it's
and i think it's
not reasoned accurately but i'm
disappointed we are disappointed by the
supreme court's ruling today
the second amendment as you've heard the
president say is not obsolete
and permits common sense gun regulation
we just received some very disturbing
news from washington
that the supreme court of the united
states of america
has stripped away the state of new
york's
right and responsibility to protect its
citizens
with a
decision which we are still digesting
which is frightful
in its scope
this decision has made every
single
one of us less safe from gun violence
the fact that the court is coming down
with this decision feels torn death and
i think i worry that it undermines the
legitimacy of the courts it seems
i don't even have the words it seems
stupid
no it's worse than that it's worse than
that it's not even stupid it is it's
it's
no it's it's so it's such a middle
finger to new york many of us are deeply
concerned and troubled by the supreme
court's ruling today
um it it i believe defies common sense
and
the constitution of the united states
frankly katie new york city will look a
lot more like alabama once this ruling
goes into place with guns widely
available with concealed carry
the mayor the governor uh let's see the
vice president the president they're all
protected by people that have guns media
mob democrats are predictably upset but
the supreme court is functioning
properly unfortunately we can't say the
same for the other two branches for
example over at the white house well
your president joe is having a really
hard time with basic tasks here we go
again take a look at your screen
apparently the white house staffers look
at that right there they had to create
this set of instructions for your
president for his meeting today that
thing there it reads quote you enter the
room you take your seat you give brief
comments you thank participants you
depart the only thing missing was you
breathe in and you breathe out don't
forget to breathe joe and if you're
really good we'll give you an extra
scoop of ice cream hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else